kollege gestanden seine zwischen frage
und dem problem von rechtsradikalen
brauche ich kein danke so heißt also
wenn sie sich das im ergebnis an kommen
ja wie ist das mit den getroffenen
leicht das merkt man dass rechtsradikale
können spalten sie können tassen sie
können an den hass appellieren und wenn
sie dann selber einmal angesprochen
werden dann reagieren sie genauso weil
sie wissen dass es stimmt schauen sie in
den spiegel dann sehen sie was diese
republik in den 20ern und 30ern seelen
geführt hat und wenn man dann von der
afg ab und zu mal sowas wie inhalte mit
kriegt dann kämpfen sie für die reichen
dann kämpfen sie gegen die rente dann
kämpfen sie gegen alles das was dieses
land zusammenhält gleichzeitig ist es so
dass die ft in diesem land die partei
ist die sich hier hinstellt und das kann
man ja beobachten
40 milliarden mehr für die verteidigung
ausgeben will aber nichts für die
rentner
man kennt das von rechtsradikalen kann
man keine lösung erwarten und wenn sie
dann hier
auch dort kann man ihn nur eins die
betreuten nehmen sind langsam mit der
nehmen sie platz
bitte nehmen sie platz trägt so weit auf
dass es im bundestag auch wieder
sachlich zu gehen kann immer dann wenn
die afg weg ist